-Good evening, everybody.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
How's everybody doing tonight?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Good to hear.
In that case,
let's get to the news.
After President Biden met last
week with the K-pop band BTS,
the White House posted a video
to Instagram that showed
Biden playing the group's
hit song, "Butter."
But they cut out the part
where he asked them to please
write a song about something
he's allowed to have.
"Smooth like hummus.
How about that?"
[ Laughter ]
President Biden delivered
an address on Thursday night
from the White House
and called on Congress
to pass gun-safety legislation,
which is kind of like
calling on the Jets
to win the Super Bowl.
You can ask.
[ Laughter ]
That's right. President Biden
delivered an address
on Thursday night
and called on Congress to ban
assault-style weapons
and expand background checks.
Or at the very least,
get rid of the vending machines.
[ Laughter ]
Dr. Mehmet Oz last week won
Pennsylvania's Republican
Senate primary,
which seems a little crazy.
I mean, is he even qualified
to be a doctor?
[ Laughter ]
The House select committee
investigating the Capitol attack
will hold its first public
hearing on Thursday,
so we can all finally get to
the bottom of that thing
the entire country watched on
live TV in real time.
[ Laughter ]
A man recently threw cake
on the protective glass of
Leonardo da Vinci's
"Mona Lisa" painting
at the Louvre in Paris.
He also threw some on a Picasso,
but no one noticed.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, we'll go after Picasso.
You're not off the hook,
Picasso.
[ Laughter ]
Yesterday was National Hot Air
Balloon Day.
This news was first reported by
a very apologetic
JetBlue gate agent.
[ Laughter ]
Baze and I talked backstage,
and we were like, "I think we
put JetBlue on the balloon."
[ Laughter ]
You know what? I don't think it
would have mattered either way.
[ Laughter ]
During a para--
So, did you guys even
understand, though?
I feel like you guys
don't even under--
[ Laughter ]
You buy a ticket
on a JetBlue flight
and then you get to the gate
and they have to apologize
and be like, "We're very sorry,
it's Hot Air Balloon Day.
You got to ride
a hot air balloon."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know --
[ Laughter ]
We were on hiatus.
We're all a little rusty.
[ Laughter ]
During a parade over the weekend
honoring her platinum jubilee,
a hologram of Queen Elizabeth
was shown in
her gold stagecoach.
And whatever you think
of the Queen,
her duet with Tupac was amazing.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, New York's
LaGuardia Airport
over the weekend debuted its
newly-renovated Terminal C,
which features an 11-lane
security screening area.
And this is cool --
one of them is open!
[ Laughter ]
And that was the monologue,
everybody.